[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Hanna
Zimmermann und Christian Siebers
hallo und guten Abend in allen der neue
Kalte Krieg auf der Erde hat das alle
erreicht eines der erfolgreichsten
wissenschaftlichen Projekte der
Menschheit steht vor dem Scheitern
die ISS ist mehr als eine Raumstation
mehr als dieses Leuchten am Himmel dass
man manchmal sehen kann sie ist trotz
und vielleicht gerade wegen all ihrer
Pannen und zu überwindenden
Herausforderungen ein internationales
Zeichen ein Außenposten im Weltraum von
16 Staaten fünf raumfahrtorganisationen
von NASA und rosskosmos zusammen
aber jetzt sagt der neue Chef der
russischen Raumfahrtbehörde russland
werde nach 2024 aussteigen und eine
eigene Raumstation Aufbauen der Weltraum
war immer schon politisch umso wichtiger
dieses Symbol des Friedens in der
Umlaufbahn dessen Zukunft jetzt mehr als
ungewiss ist Lara Wiedeking und Simon
rubesch berichten
es ist November 1998 das erste Bauteil
für die ISS startet mit einer russischen
Trägerrakete ins Weltall die erste Crew
auf der Raumstation zwei Jahre später
besteht aus einem amerikanischen
Astronauten und zwei russischen
Kosmonauten
nichts hier oben funktioniert ohne den
anderen gemeinsam leben gemeinsam
forschen nach dem jahrelangen Wettrennen
im Weltall ist die ISS ein Leuchtturm
der Kooperation damit ist wohl bald
Schluss man wolle nur dennoch
bestehenden Verpflichtung nachkommen
sagt der neue Chef der russischen
Raumfahrtbehörde die Entscheidung ist
gefallen wir ziehen uns von der Station
2024 zurück ich glaube bis dahin werden
wir beginnen eine russische
weltraumbasis aufzubauen
so soll sie später mal aussehen die neue
russische Raumstation außerdem erklären
die Russen sie wollten ihren Teil der
ISS eventuell abkoppeln und alleine
betreiben Russland liefert unter anderem
die Korrektur des Orbits das heißt es
hebt die Raumstation immer wieder an mit
seinen Raumfahrzeugen die amerikanische
Seite also die westliche Seite liefert
Kommunikation Strom das auseinander zu
dividieren wird sehr schwierig vor nicht
einmal fünf Tagen haben einen Russe und
eine Europäerin gemeinsam an der ISS
gearbeitet
und Samantha Christopher retti
internationales Teamwork das in der
Vergangenheit von Putin hochgelobt wurde
wir freuen uns dass unsere Spezialisten
erfolgreich im iss-programm mit ihren
Kollegen aus dem Vereinigten Staaten
einer der führenden weltraumnationen
zusammenarbeiten es ist ein
spektakuläres Beispiel wie die wirksame
Partnerschaft unser beider Länder zum
Wohle der gesamten Menschheit eingesetzt
wird
bisher schwebt die ISS über den
politischen Entwicklungen auf der Erde
Nationalitäten und Grenzen spielen hier
oben keine Rolle spätestens mit der
heutigen Ankündigung ist allerdings klar
die Zeitenwende ist auch im Weltraum
angekommen
der deutsche Astronaut Reinhold Ewald
war selbst im All auf der russischen
Station mir er ist jetzt Professor am
Institut für raumfahrtssysteme und bei
uns aus Stuttgart Herr Ewald guten Abend
guten Abend was haben Sie denn gefühlt
als diese Nachricht heute kam
oh bitte nicht das ist ein Verfremdung
der Partnerschaft die wir jetzt seit
vielen vielen Jahren bei der
internationalen Raumstation haben zu
politischen Zwecken das gebührt ja nicht
dazu ist sie nicht da und dazu
verdeckt das auf die Leistungen dieser
internationalen Raumstation es ist ja
bislang immer politische Probleme
bleiben auf der Erde Staatsangehörigkeit
sei kein Thema auf der ISS wie haben sie
das denn selbst erlebt naja der Blick
auf die Erde zeigt eben keine Grenzen
und gerade diese internationale
Zusammenarbeit das füreinander einstehen
um Erfolg zu haben angesichts der großen
Aufgaben der Raumfahrt das prägt ja
diese Zusammenarbeit dann nach
Raumstation deshalb heißt das ja auch
Partnerschaft also ist es tatsächlich so
da oben dass es egal ist ob man jetzt
Russe ist Amerikaner Deutscher oder
sonst woher kommt
na egal es ist nicht weil man natürlich
unterschiedliche Trainingsabläufe hat
und unterschiedliche Kenntnisse damit
bringt aber aus diesen Teilstücken wird
dann ein ganzes also da möchten wir
eigentlich nicht auf die russische
Erfahrung die Unterstützung durch das
bodenkontrollzentrum Verzichten jetzt
was in der letzten Zeit allerdings auch
schon so das konnte man ja beobachten
dass russische Kosmonauten zum Beispiel
auf der ISS die hatten dann plötzlich
Fahnen von selbsternannten
Volksrepubliken in der Ostukraine dabei
und sagten wir feiern Russlands
Kriegsziele auch im Weltraum woher kommt
das das schmerzt das Schmerz aus meiner
langjährigen Zusammenarbeit mit den
russischen Kollegen und ich will mir gar
nicht vorstellen welcher Druck da
ausgeübt wurde auf jeden Fall ist es
nicht förderlich für die Zusammenarbeit
also da gilt auch dort Arzt und tell ich
meine wir haben genug da oben zu tun
ohne über Politik zu diskutieren und so
werden es dann auch die Kolleginnen und
die Kollegen aus dem westlichen Segment
dann halten
lassen Sie uns über die technischen
folgen jetzt reden stürzt die ISS ab
wenn Russland sich zurückzieht nein das
ist schon orbital-technisch
ausgeschlossen es ist ja so dass die
Partner sich sowieso alle bis 2024
erstmal geeinigt haben da gibt es
natürlich jetzt in der Partnerschaft bei
Isa und auch bei den äh bei der NASA
Töne die sagen also wir wollen doch
durchaus bis 2030 gehen das hat Russland
jetzt erstmal in Frage gestellt aber wir
sind ja noch nicht bei 2024 und da gibt
es auch noch Zeit die Vor- und Nachteile
doch gründlich zu erwägen bevor man so
einen Schritt macht das heißt sie gehen
davon aus dass Russland vielleicht auch
wieder Rückzieher macht und oder es nur
blöd war Propaganda im weitesten Sinne
und das am Ende doch weitergeht aus der
täglichen Zusammenarbeit wissen wir dass
die Russen von den Fähigkeiten auch des
westlichen Segments sage ich mal der
anderen Partner sehr stark profitieren
ob das jetzt die Datenverbindung ist
oder auch die der Bezug von elektrischer
Energie das müsste man ja alles wenn man
die Raumstation isoliert als russische
Ladestation betreiben wollte ab 24
wieder hochfahren das sehe ich sehr
skeptisch wäre es denn möglich dass die
ISS alleine durch den Westen weiter am
Leben gehalten wird ja das ist aber die
schlechtere Variante denn wir haben ja
gesehen wenn ein System ausfällt ist es
guten Backup-System zu haben im Falle
des amerikanischen Space Shuttle war es
lange Zeit die Sojus Rakete die dann
Menschen zur Raumstation gebracht hat
das würde natürlich wegfallen das heißt
wir verlieren wir nennen das Redundanz
wir verlieren einfach eine zweite Säule
jetzt hat Russland heute auch
angekündigt eine eigene Raumstation
aufbauen zu wollen wie realistisch ist
das aus ihrer Sicht
die
Bestandteile der russischen Raumstation
wurden ja schon mit Haken Verzögerungen
und auch Schwierigkeiten jetzt zur
Raumstation gebracht das letzte war
übrigens vor ein paar Monaten ein
wissenschaftsmodul naruka wenn das 2024
alles Makulatur wird hat Russland einen
Riesenverlust an Investitionen an
erlitten die Analyse des deutschen
Astronauten Reinhold Ewald Herr Ewald
herzlichen Dank für das Gespräch gerne
hoffen auf bessere Zeiten absolut
ja und das Gespräch haben wir
aufgezeichnet vor dieser Sendung aus
Termin Gründen ganz irdische Probleme
die ebenfalls auf den russischen Krieg
gegen die Ukraine zurückgehen waren
heute Thema in Brüssel Europa sucht
einen Weg aus der gasnot und zwar einen
gemeinsamen nicht einfach denn wieder
einmal wirkt die Europäische Union wie
ein Verein in dem sehr viele wenn es
richtig eng wird erstmal an sich selbst
denken wer also einen Notfallplan
erwartet als klare Handlungsanweisung
bei der jedes Land seinen Teil leisten
muss der wird enttäuscht Europas
einsparplan für Gas der heute
beschlossen wurde ist EU pur durchsetzt
mit Kompromissen und ausnahmeklauseln
mehr dazu aus Brüssel von Florian
Neuhann
die Aussicht in seinem Büro direkt vor
dem Eiffelturm in Paris Mark traumhaft
sein der Ausblick den fatibirolle dann
im ZDF-Interview liefert ist es nicht
Frage an den Chef der Internationalen
Energieagentur ist Europa vorbereitet
auf dem nächsten Winter
absolut nicht wir sind hinter dem
Zeitplan wenn wir nicht ernsthafte
Maßnahmen ergreifen könnte es zu
größeren Engpässen bei der Gasversorgung
kommen
meine Ansicht nach wird dieser Winter
ein historischer Test für Europa
will be Historik test for Europe es ist
ein Test bei dem sie heute die erste
Etappe bestehen müssen Sondersitzung der
EU Energieminister in Brüssel wir spart
wie viel wir teilt seinen Gas mit
anderen ein Treffen bei dem heftiger
Streit erwartet wurde und bei dem dann
öffentlich das Gegenteil geboten wird
heute senden wir ein starkes Signal
nicht nur an Wladimir Putin dem es
erneut nicht gelungen ist die
Europäische Union zu spalten
gerade im Energie- und Klimabereich hat
Europa in den letzten Wochen und Monaten
eine große ich würde fast sagen
erstaunliche Geschlossenheit geschafft
und das auch heute was die EU-Staaten
heute verabreden dass sie ihren
Gasverbrauch von August bis März um 15%
verringern wollen klingt gut ist aber
nur möglich dank zahlreicher Ausnahmen
für Inselstaaten für Länder die nur
wenige gasverbindungen zu anderen haben
für ganze Industriebereiche und vor
allem nur auf freiwilliger Basis es ist
ein Plan bei dem sich mancher schon an
diesem Tag in Brüssel und anderswo fragt
ob das eigentlich ausreicht
15 Prozent ist wahrscheinlich nicht
genug wenn man sieht dass Russland
gerade seine Gaslieferungen über Nord
Stream 1 weiter verringert aber es ist
besser als
unsere Ansicht nach müssen wir selbst
wenn alles andere perfekt läuft 20
Prozent des Gasverbrauchs in Europa
einsparen um ein großes Problem im
Winter zu verhindern ihr wollt imagine
Problem in winter in Europe darüber wie
die EU-Staaten ihr Gas einsparen sorgt
der Notfallplan übrigens herzlich wenig
womöglich so fragt sich der slowakische
Wirtschaftsminister am Ende dieses Tages
ist es ja gar nicht der eu-plan der zum
gasparen verleitet
die Verbraucher sparen Gas und werden
gar sparen deswegen weil weil jetzt
einmal teurer ist und nicht weil die EU
da sagt Europa rüstet sich für einen
Krisen Winter und nicht weniger rechnen
damit dass sie sich bald wieder hier
treffen müssen wenn die eigenen
Einsparziele verfehlt werden
europäische Solidarität sieht dann heute
auch so aus Spanien etwa ist
hochzufrieden über diesen eu-kompromiss
Spaniens Energieministerin sagt es sei
unmöglich für politische Fehler
Deutschlands zu bezahlen
bezahlen für diese Fehler werden also
vor allem wir selbst und Deutschland
wird auch wohl deutlich mehr Gas
einsparen müssen als andere Länder
natürlich können große
Industrieunternehmen jetzt nicht da
sitzen und hoffen dass alles halbwegs
glimpflich abgehen möge einen Plan B
muss her ein eigener Sparplan Peter
Kunst zeigt das am Beispiel von
Deutschlands zweitgrößtem Stahlerzeuger
in Salzgitter
europäische Kriegswirtschaft die
deutsche Industrie stellt sich darauf
ein ohne Gas geht es bei
salzgitter-stahl nicht mit weniger Gas
schon ob wir damit am Ende des Tages 15
Prozent einsparen kann ich Ihnen heute
noch nicht sagen wir haben zum Beispiel
an einigen der der
wärmeöfen vorwärme Einrichtungen
abgeschaltet damit braucht die
Vorwärmung etwas länger das kompensieren
wir mit mehr Personal lohnt sich aber
aufgrund der hohen Energiepreise aktuell
teures Gas macht automatisch sparsamer
der Politik hilft das bei ihren Appellen
die Salzgitter AG versucht in ihrem
Hüttenwerk ohnehin Energie in
Kreisläufen aufzubereiten modern
gesteuert aus dem historischen Kraftwerk
Windräder auf dem eigenen Gelände die
Krise als Chance begreifen so rüstet
sich der Konzern für diesen harten
Winter und kommende wir haben jetzt vor
zehn Tagen die Investitionsentscheidung
getroffen hier am Standort Salzgitter
einen der Hochöfen zu ersetzen durch
neue Technologie beziehungsweise mit
Erdgas aber in der Zielrichtung mit
Wasserstoff und vielleicht hilft er
diese Gaskrise aktuell auch den Aufbau
von wasserstoffkapazitäten zu
beschleunigen und uns damit noch
schneller den Umstieg zu ermöglichen
weniger Abhängigkeit weniger CO2 das
Ziel ist mit Wasserstoff produzierter
grüner Stahl eine probeanlage steht in
Salzgitter schon jetzt
wenn wir diese Anlage in einen großen
Maßstab überführen wird es eine
Einrichtung sein mit einer Höhe von über
130 Metern Türme wie Hochhäuser in denen
dem Eisen das Oxid entzogen wird sie
sollen langfristig die Hochöfen ersetzen
die Zukunft hat nur einen Haken für den
Übergang plants Salzgitter mit einem
Wasserstoff Mix und braucht dafür sogar
mehr Erdgas als heute zum einen brauchen
wir das Gas erst in 2025 und den
Folgejahren bis dahin glaube ich nicht
dass wir noch eine Gaskrise in dem Maße
diskutieren wie sie heute diskutieren
und zum anderen sagt der Chef eines der
größten Stahlproduzenten Europas sollte
sich Deutschland nicht von zu viel Angst
in dieser Krise lähmen lassen was ist
mit seiner eigenen Angst dass hier das
Gas abgestellt wird zum einen versorgen
wir die Stadt Salzgitter mit Fernwärme
das können wir natürlich nur machen wenn
der Standort läuft zum zweiten sind wir
drittgrößter Versorger mit Trinkwasser
für das Land Niedersachsen und das
dritte ist dass wir
die Verbindungsleitung für die
Anschlüsse der lng-terminals in
Wilhelmshaven und in Brunsbüttel hier am
Standort fertigen und das heißt die
Energiewende kann nur funktionieren wenn
wir Stahl haben kann nur funktionieren
wenn wir hier auch entsprechend
produzieren ohne Stahlröhren aus
Salzgitter kein Anschluss von
flüssiggasterminals keine schnelle
Energieunabhängigkeit das ist Gas
Kriegswirtschaft und sie ist komplex
und den Blick auf die aktuelle Lage in
der Ukraine hat jetzt du Hannah und da
kam heute die Meldung dass die Ukraine
weitere schwere Waffen aus Deutschland
erhalten hat drei zugesagte mehrfacher
kettenwerfer vom Typ Mars 2 sind im
Kriegsgebiet angekommen und außerdem
weitere Panzerhaubitzen 2000 unterdessen
hat Russland die Südküste der Ukraine
massiv beschossen im Badeort satoka
wurden viele Häuser zerstört und auch
der Süden der Region mikolaje vor der
bombardiert
Käufer von Elektroautos sollen ab dem
kommenden Jahr weniger Förderprämie
bekommen so soll es nach Medienberichten
statt 6000 Euro nur noch 4.500 Euro für
Fahrzeuge geben die weniger als 40.000
Euro kosten 3000 Euro sind bei teureren
E-Autos bis 65.000 Euro vorgesehen der
Zuschuss für Plug-in-Hybride soll Ende
des laufenden Jahres komplett
abgeschafft werden die Einigung ist
morgen Thema im Kabinett
vor dem Bundesverfassungsgericht ging es
heute um den 750 Milliarden Euro
schweren Corona wiederaufbaufond der EU
das Geld soll Mitgliedsstaaten helfen
nach der Pandemie wirtschaftlich wieder
auf die Beine zu kommen dafür werden
gemeinsam Schulden aufgenommen genau das
halten die Kläger allerdings für
unzulässig sie sehen und kalkulierbare
Haftungsrisiken für den Bundeshaushalt
morgen wird die Verhandlung fortgesetzt
das Urteil ist frühestens in einigen
Monaten zu erwarten
13 Monate nach einer tödlichen
Messerattacke auf Passanten in Würzburg
hat das zuständige Landgericht
entschieden den Angeklagten auf
unbefristete Zeit in einer Psychiatrie
unterzubringen das Gericht sieht es als
erwiesen an dass der 32-Jährige zum
Zeitpunkt der Tat schuldunfähig war zwei
Gutachten bescheinigten dem Mann
paranoide Schizophrenie der auch Somalia
stammende geflüchtete hatte im Juni 2021
in einem Kaufhaus drei ihm unbekannte
Frauen mit einem Küchenmesser getötet
und etliche weitere verletzt
[Musik]
die Flammen kennen keine Grenzen die
Flammen machen nicht halt vor besonders
schützenswerten Naturreservaten die
Feuerwehren kämpfen aber Sie bekommen
die Lage nicht unter Kontrolle vom
Nationalpark Böhmische Schweiz in
Tschechien wo sich die waldbrandlage
seit Tagen dramatisch zu spitzt hat das
Feuer auch auf den Nationalparks
Sächsische Schweiz übergegriffen auch
dort ist die Situation sehr schwierig
genauso wie in Brandenburg wo eine
Fläche fast so groß wie 1200
Fußballfelder brennt
die Folgen der Klimakrise mit großer
Hitze und vor allem mit statistisch
ungewöhnlich starker Trockenheit ist für
jede und jeden zu sehen in diesem Sommer
auch dort wohin wir extra fahren um
vermeintlich intakte Natur zu bestaunen
und zu genießen wo es eisig sein sollte
und wo sie jetzt viele Fotos machen
damit auch die Kleinsten später noch
nachvollziehen können wie es dort mal
ausgesehen hat Stefan leifert war in den
Alpen unterwegs
wo heute der Hubschrauber landet war vor
100 Jahren noch Gletscher mit 50 Kilo
Messgeräten im Gepäck begleiten wir
Eichstätter Geographen auf den gepatsch
ferner hoch oben in den Ötztaler Alpen
da sind wir bei maximalen rückschmelz
Raten von über 100 Metern pro Jahr wenn
es sehr warme Jahre sind
der Gebhardt ferner ist der am
schnellsten schmelzende Gletscher der
Alpen jedes Jahr kommt Florian Haas mit
seinem Team hierher die Daten der
gletscherforscher lesen sich wie ein
Protokoll des Klimawandels der Gepard
Sperner ist ein Ort an dem man die
folgende Erderwärmung sehen und hören
kann
das ist Schmelzwasser von Gletscher also
wir sind jetzt hier in dem Bereich wo
wir eigentlich schon den Schnee des
Winters nicht mehr drauf haben also
alles was jetzt hier oberflächlich
schmilzt ist das was durch die warmen
Temperaturen der vergangenen Tage und
jetzt durch die Sonneneinstrahlung mit
in Verbindung mit diesem dunklen Schmutz
dann anfängt oberflächlich am Gletscher
zu schmelzen
[Musik]
wo das Auge hinsieht tropft fließt und
plätschert es es ist ein Besuch am
Sterbebett der Gletscher
mit Ihren Daten beschreiben die
geographenveränderungen und Gefahren
nach dem schneearmen Winter und in einem
warmen Sommer wie diesem Schrumpf der
besonders stark wo Gletscher schmelzen
geraten ganze Landschaften in Bewegung
hänge drohen abzustürzen mit Erdrutschen
bis ins Tal es gibt auch so extrem
Beispiele wie wir wie wir jetzt hier
haben beobachten mit unseren Scans und
richtig großen feldsturz wo teilweise
der ganze der ganze Hang in Bewegung ist
also so ein Absacken was eben eine Folge
daraus ist dass der Gletscher so stark
einschmilzt pro Jahr verliert der
gepatsch ferner über 100 Meter seiner
Länge durch die weltweite Gletscher
Schmelze steigen die Meeresspiegel das
Klimagerät dadurch noch stärker aus dem
Gleichgewicht
für ihre Forschung sammeln die
Geographen Fotos der Bevölkerung bis
zurück ins 19 Jahrhundert sie zeigen wie
sich der Klimawandel durch eine ganze
Landschaft Frist
ich zeig die Fotos auf mein Sohn der ist
jetzt acht Jahre alt meine Tochter ist 6
und ich habe so die Zweifel ob die noch
so viele Gletscher sehen können das ist
einfach so dass man schon daneben steht
und wirklich erschrocken ist welche
Geschwindigkeit des angenommen hat das
war bis zu den 90ern war sehr
einigermaßen stabil wir sind
zurückgeschmolzen aber relativ stabil
eure seitdem ist es wirklich sehr sehr
drastisch wo die beiden Forscher heute
laufen wird 2050 gar kein Eis mehr sein
auch bei bestem Klimaschutz wird die
Schmelze 3 Jahrzehnte weitergehen mit
den Gletschern schmilzt auch der Mythos
vom ewigen Eis
der Berg ruft um Hilfe und er zieht sie
an die Berg verrückten und Berg
verliebten vielleicht ist es ja diese
Begeisterung der Menschen für
Höhenrausch und Leidenschaft in den
Alpen die dazu führt dass wir alle
aufwachen und bewahren was da gerade
zugrunde geht das ZDF nimmt sie mit in
diesem Sommer in gebirgswelten die Alpen
machen am Donnerstag um 22 Uhr den
Anfang es lohnt sich dabei zu sein auch
jetzt bereits via ZDF Mediathek
so und auch heute noch mal Hannah der
bange Blick auf den lufthansa-flugplan
von morgen ja ganz genau die Lufthansa
hat auf den angekündigten Warnstreik des
Bodenpersonals reagiert und zwar mit
drastischen Streichungen im Flugplan
morgen fallen mehr als 1000 Flüge an den
Drehkreuzen Frankfurt und München aus
und die Auswirkungen Frank die könnten
auch noch länger spürbar sein sagt die
Airline ja voraussichtlich bis
Donnerstag oder gar Freitag am
Wochenende wolle man alles wieder im
Griff haben hieß es heute von der
Lufthansa natürlich auch mit dem Blick
auf die dann beginnenden Ferien in
Bayern und Baden-Württemberg am
Frankfurter Flughafen dagegen bereits
heute die ersten Flugausfälle insgesamt
werden alleine hier heute und morgen 678
Flüge gestrichen betroffen davon
92.000 Fluggäste die ohne eine Umbuchung
gar nicht erst zum Flughafen kommen
sollen waren die Airline die ersten
Betroffenen sind unter anderem
Passagiere die morgen früh eigentlich
von Fernsehen auf deutschen Flughäfen
landen wollten Abflüge von Bangkok Soul
oder New York beispielsweise ihre
Maschinen sind gar nicht erst gestartet
wie die Lufthansa vorhin mitteilte
ja und das ist ja nun nicht die einzige
Baustelle der Lufthansa nein auch die
Piloten Drohnen mit Streik am Sonntag
läuft die uhrabstimmung darüber ab käme
ist auch da zu Arbeitsniederlegungen
würde fliegen noch mehr zum Glücksspiel
also keine wirklich guten Aussichten
weder für die Lufthansa Kunden noch für
die Airline selbst Deutschlands größte
Fluggesellschaft verspielt ihre
Verlässlichkeit insgesamt zu viele
hausgemachte Probleme auch hier an der
Börse die Lufthansa nicht mehr hoch im
Kurs die Aktie tendiert seit geraumer
Zeit abwärts vielen Dank nach Frankfurt
ein weiteres Mal hat der Internationale
Währungsfonds seine globale
Wachstumsprognose für das laufende Jahr
gesenkt wegen des Kriegs in der Ukraine
und der hohen Inflation werde die
Weltwirtschaft mit 3,2 Prozent um 0,4
Punkte langsamer wachsen als noch immer
April angenommen in der Eurozone wird
nun ein Wachstum von 2,6% erwartet das
sind 0,2 Punkte weniger als zuvor
morgen geht es für die deutsche
Nationalmannschaft gegen Frankreich um
den Einzug ins Finale der
frauenfußball-em übrigens zu sehen ab 20
Uhr hier im ZDF und seit heute Abend ist
klar sollte die DFB-Elf dabei siegen
würde sie im Endspiel auf England
treffen
es sind Tränen des Glücks sie können es
nicht fassen dir Druck für die
Gastgeberinnen im Vorfeld so immens groß
nun wird er aber wahr der Traum vom
Finale nach einem traumhaften Spiel nach
einem Fußballfest mit spektakulären
Touren zur Pause steht's 1:0 für England
nur 1:0 aber nach dem Seitenwechsel gibt
es dann kein Halten mehr Lucy Browns
trifft zum 2:0 und dann dieses
hammerhackentor von Alicia Russo an
diesem Abend klappt bei den
Gastgeberinnen einfach alles und bei den
Schwedinnen geht alles schief am Ende
sogar 4:0 für England durch Kirby
Fußballherz was willst du mehr naja ein
Finale mit Deutschland wäre nicht
schlecht
[Applaus]
er gilt als die Koryphäe der
Klezmermusik biora Fatman hat heute zu
seinem 75
Bühnenjubiläum ein Konzert in Berlin
gegeben und im Jüdischen Museum eine
seiner Klarinetten für die
Dauerausstellung vermacht der 86-Jährige
hat selbst jüdische Wurzeln und setzt
sich seit langem für die
deutsch-jüdische Aussöhnung ein
wir haben heute begonnen in dieser
Sendung mit dem Blick auf Russland auf
die neue Eiszeit im All auf die Sorge
vor gasnotstand und auf Appelle zum
Energiesparen wir enden mit dem Blick
aus Moskau auf uns hier es ist der
offizielle Blick der staatlich streng
kontrollierte der einzige der viele
Menschen in Russland erreicht für begann
60 Minuten heißt die Sendung von Olgas
gabijeva seitdem russische Soldaten in
der Ukraine kämpfen ist sie doppelt so
lang und sendet zweimal täglich eines
ihrer Hauptthemen derzeit die deutsche
Sorge um die Energiesicherheit
absolut beängstigend dieses Bild ruft
dazu auf nur vier Körperteile zu waschen
um den Präsidenten zu ärgern das ist
eine Sensation
am letzten Satz selbst der Präsident
kommentiert das comic-bild das vor allem
auf pro russischen Social Media Kanälen
Kurs
willst du Wladimir Putin ärgern dann
wasche nur diese vier Stellen
was soll das sind die verrückt geworden
spart Wasser spart Strom spart Energie
das ist alles Quatsch sie haben Fehler
gemacht und jetzt wissen sie nicht wie
sie damit umgehen sollen
ohne russisches Gas drohe Deutschland
ein kalter winterberichten die
staatskanäle und im Internet wird
gewitzelt
was passiert wenn Europa das Gas
abgestellt wird
[Musik]
Deutschland reicht dir das amerikanische
Gas danke aber nein singt es als Antwort
[Musik]
die Propaganda wirke sagt Alexander
minking der Journalist hat im März bei
der Zeitung moskowski komm zu Moritz
gekündigt weil er nicht mehr er trug was
dort veröffentlicht wurde
ich gebe es in Russland eine freie
Presse dann würde das staatliche
lügensystem zusammenbrechen
einstürzen wie ein gesprenktes Haus
zunehmende Isolation steigende
Lebensmittelpreise es gibt viel worüber
sich Russinnen und Russen Sorgen machen
könnten die Propaganda lenkt davon ab
macht glauben die Not der anderen derer
im Westen sei noch viel größer man darf
das Gas nicht abschalten das sind doch
auch Menschen es wird kalt sie werden
frieren sie strangulieren sich selbst
wir müssen gar nichts Besonderes machen
sie sehen doch dass all ihre Probleme
auf die eigenen Handlungen
zurückzuführen sind
ein Satz wir fast wörtlich zigmal im
Staatsfernsehen gesagt wurde dort wird
beleidigt gedroht und immer die eigene
Stärke betont Schulz Schulz kapier 1 es
wird keine Niederlage Russlands geben
eine Niederlage Russlands bedeutet die
Vernichtung der ganzen Welt
eine Gedankenwelt die in Russland
tagtäglich über den Bildschirm flimmert
und längst in die Gesellschaft
ausgestrahlt hat
im Ranking zur Pressefreiheit von
Reporter ohne Grenzen liegt Russland auf
Platz 155 zwischen Aserbaidschan und
Afghanistan
was wird aus unseren Träumen darum geht
es gleich nach uns bei 37 Grad zwei
Familien die aus der Ukraine geflohen
sind und sich in einem Dorf im
Oberbergischen Land wiederfinden stehen
vor der Frage wie es weitergehen kann
gleich hier im ZDF
wir sehen uns dann morgen wieder wenn
Sie mögen tschüss für heute ein
angenehmen Abend
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter viel zu trocken
ist es in Teilen Europas und so geht es
weiter schon wieder dehnt sich ein Hoch
aus und es erreicht auch Deutschland das
Tief hier wird weggeschoben und
dazwischen kommt kühlere Luft aus dem
Nordwesten zu uns aus nördlichen
Richtungen ja und das macht einfach das
Wetter erträglicher in der Nacht gibt es
noch etwas Regen das lässt aber
allmählich nach und dann wird es trocken
wie in den anderen Regionen auch und das
bei tiefsten Temperaturen im Norden
vorbei 9 bis 13 Grad also hier die
Nordhälfte deutlich kühler als der Süden
und spürt also das kühlere Luft
eingeflossen ist aber im Südwesten ist
es am mildesten hier Richtung
Rhein-Main-Gebiet mit 16 Grad und morgen
im Tagesverlauf wird ein kräftiger Wind
aus nordwestlichen Richtung kann auch
mal stürmisch sein und es gibt im Norden
mehr Wolken als im am besten einzig nach
Südosten in Richtung Bayern hier über
den Bergen Schauer und Gewitter können
lokal dann kräftigen Regen bringen aber
der Regen ist eben dann nur lokal und
das bei höchsten Temperaturen von 25 bis
27 Grad nach Süden hin deutlich kühler
im Norden bei 17 bis 20 Grad bis in die
norddeutsche Tiefebene die kommenden
Tage am Donnerstag wieder im Süden
hauptsächlich Gewitter sonst trockenes
Wetter bei 19 bis 31 Grad freitags sind
die schauen und Gewitter dann durchaus
häufiger aber auch wieder nur lokal und
damit ein schöner Abend